what are some of the biggest lessons  you've learned from working with him so  closely you know bill has his way i have  my way but i think just being honest one  thing i learned i remember one time i  told a joke and there was like an  exaggerated part of the joke and he goes  all right now tell me what really  happened so it was like yeah that's  exaggerated but how did it really happen  and then you say how really happy he's  like see that's funny or as funny so  that was one thing that i remember when  i was younger i can't remember the joke  exactly it was a strip club joke you  know i was too nice last time i was a  strip club i actually tried talking her  out of her lifestyle  i'm like why are you doing this  i was like people love you like you got  to get out of here and she was like dude  are you a cop  and  but but my  my version of it was like something  exaggerated right  no that's funny but i tried to make it  some different thing